The following episode of How We Made Your Mother was recorded live on Instagram on February 4th, 2026.
《我们如何创造你的母亲》的下一集于 2026 年 2 月 4 日在 Instagram 上现场录制。
We are live.
我们还活着。
Oh, we are live on Instagram.
哦，我们在 Instagram 上直播。
It's happening.
它正在发生。
Hi.
你好。
It's all happening.
这一切都在发生。
Hi Craig Thomas.
嗨克雷格·托马斯。
Josh Radner and other people that we don't know.
乔什·拉德纳和其他我们不认识的人。
Hello people who are joining us, Josh Radner.
加入我们的人们大家好，乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner)。
This is my friend Craig Thomas.
这是我的朋友克雷格·托马斯。
Craig co-created a show called How I Met Your Mother with Carter Baze that I was on for nine years.
克雷格与卡特·贝兹共同创作了一部名为《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的节目，我在这个节目上待了九年。
I played Ted Mosby on that show.
我在那场演出中扮演泰德·莫斯比。
We're doing a podcast now called How We Made Your Mother where we're re-watching all of the episodes.
我们现在正在制作一个名为“我们如何创造了你的母亲”的播客，我们将在其中重新观看所有剧集。
My wife, Jordana had never seen the show, so she wanted to watch it, and I called Craig, and I said, look, I'm gonna show my wife this show we made.
我的妻子乔丹娜从未看过这个节目，所以她想看，我打电话给克雷格，我说，看，我要给我妻子看我们制作的这个节目。
Do you wanna do something a little more formal on the record?
你想做一些更正式的记录吗？
Maybe we can revisit it and talk about it, and that's what we've been doing.
也许我们可以重新审视它并讨论它，这就是我们一直在做的事情。
We're two seasons deep.
我们已经两季了。
It's crazy.
太疯狂了。
We haven't, not all of the second season has dropped yet, but we are what, Alec, would you say, like early middle season two is currently dropping week by week?
我们还没有，第二季还没有全部结束，但我们是什么，亚历克，你会说，第二季早期中期目前每周都在下降吗？
Something like that, producer Aklev here.
类似的事情，制片人阿克列夫在这里。
That's right.
这是正确的。
we're in it.
我们就在其中。
We are deep into season two and we want to do these IG Labs sometimes just to help get the word out and and find more people.
我们已经进入第二季了，有时我们想做这些 IG 实验室，只是为了帮助宣传并找到更多人。
I had this experience where I went into the how I met your mother bar in New York City.
我有过这样的经历，当时我走进了纽约市的“我是如何遇见你母亲的”酒吧。
It is the bar of how much mother because it's where Carter and I used to go to drink after taping late show with David Letterman when we were in our 20s when we were writers for that show.
这是“多少妈妈”的酒吧，因为当我们 20 多岁的时候，当我们担任大卫·莱特曼的深夜节目的编剧时，卡特和我经常去那里喝酒。
And I had the experience recently of going in there And the bartender at the bar, who's very nice, who I've known 13 years, said, are you doing a podcast?
我最近有过一次去那里的经历，酒吧里的调酒师非常好，我认识他 13 年了，他说，你在做播客吗？
She's like, Irish, you're doing a podcast?
她说，爱尔兰人，你在做播客吗？
I didn't know, I'm like, if the bartender at the how much your mother bar doesn't know we're doing a podcast, we are shitting them if something is going wrong here.
我不知道，我想，如果你妈妈酒吧的调酒师不知道我们在做播客，如果这里出了问题，我们就会拉屎他们。
So I was like, we gotta get the word out more.
所以我想，我们必须更多地宣传。
Now, also though, we should be clear.
但现在我们也应该清楚了。
There's a lot of people listening to the podcast.
有很多人在听播客。
It's just relative to the world of how I met your mother fans.
这只是与我认识你妈妈粉丝的世界有关。
There's more people that we think would be enjoying this thing we're doing, right?
我们认为会有更多的人喜欢我们正在做的事情，对吗？
Yes, to be clear, we're happy with it as it is.
是的，需要明确的是，我们对现状感到满意。
We just want it to be bigger.
我们只是希望它更大。
And we want your questions.
我们希望您提出问题。
We want you to tell a friend, and it's very interactive.
我们希望您告诉朋友，这是非常互动的。
It's very fan-forward, this podcast, right?
这个播客非常受粉丝欢迎，对吧？
We started every episode with a voice note from a fan about what how I met your mother means to them.
我们每集都以粉丝的语音留言开始，讲述我如何遇见你母亲对他们意味着什么。
We end every episode with a letter, a written letter from a viewer, a fan.
我们以一封信结束每一集，一封来自观众、粉丝的书面信。
And if you want to participate in that way, go to how we made your mother.com, h-w-m-y-m.com.
如果您想以这种方式参与，请访问我们如何创建您的 mother.com，h-w-m-y-m.com。
Go to contact and just follow the directions.
前往联系方式并按照说明操作即可。
you can either leave a voice note or an email.
您可以留下语音留言或电子邮件。
And maybe, there's a good chance your letter might end up on the air.
也许，你的信很有可能最终会被播出。
What are we, what would you say guiding people?
我们是什么，你会说什么引导人们？
Like, what do we respond to in terms of the letters?
比如，我们用字母来回应什么？
Well, we ask, we ask episode specific, right?
好吧，我们问，我们问具体的情节，对吧？
Every week, Alex, Lab, that you are posting things that say, do you have any questions about, for example, this week is Monday Night Football.
每周，亚历克斯，实验室，你都会发布一些内容，说你有什么问题吗，例如，本周是周一橄榄球之夜。
That season two episode Monday Night Football.
该季第二集《周一橄榄球之夜》。
Did you have any questions about that?
您对此有任何疑问吗？
And we just did it.
我们刚刚做到了。
That's the one where they tried not to learn who won the Super Bowl for 24 hours.
他们试图在 24 小时内不知道谁赢得了超级碗。
so they could watch it together.
这样他们就可以一起观看。
The sensory depurator 5000, which is a device a lot of people wish they were wearing every day as the news rolls in, but we won't go there.
感官净化器 5000，这是很多人希望在新闻报道时每天佩戴的设备，但我们不会去那里。
I bet you could mark it.
我打赌你可以标记它。
I bet we could sell in the premium gift shop.
我打赌我们可以在高级礼品店出售。
We could sell sensory depurator 3000.
我们可以销售感官净化器 3000 台。
Here's your 2026 sensory depurator.
这是您的 2026 感官净化器。
We'll see you in 27.
我们27号见。
We'll see you check in again how it's going.
我们将再次查看您的情况。
Yeah.
是的。
So we asked episode web.
所以我们询问了剧集网络。
So the more, Alec, I have a feeling this would be your answer.
所以，亚历克，我有一种感觉，这就是你的答案。
the more specific, the better the questions.
问题越具体，越好。
Yes.
是的。
So what's the specific?
那么具体是什么呢？
Right, so what happens is before we do an episode, we ask for episode specific questions, but for those letters that people are writing in.
是的，所以在我们制作一集之前，我们会询问特定于剧集的问题，但是对于人们写的那些信件。
That can be interesting.
这可能很有趣。
That thought episode specific.
那一集具体的想法。
Yeah, I think, I would say that, I mean, we have thousands, we have thousands of these letters and our co-producer Doug goes through them and finds them and our social media producer, Emily, she goes through them to find them.
是的，我想，我会说，我的意思是，我们有数千封这样的信件，我们的联合制片人道格浏览它们并找到它们，我们的社交媒体制作人艾米丽则浏览它们并找到它们。
And I think that we look for specific stories about your life, you know?
我认为我们会寻找有关您生活的具体故事，您知道吗？
We know you love the show, everyone loves the show.
我们知道您喜欢这个节目，每个人都喜欢这个节目。
How did it intersect with your life?
它是如何与你的生活相交的？
What does him mean to you?
他对你来说意味着什么？
Yeah, that's a good point, I got it.
是的，这是一个很好的观点，我明白了。
There's a big difference there.
这里面有很大的区别。
We like episode specific questions to do in our sort of general questions, general questions in the episode, about the episode, but the letters or voice notes you could leave us, just like, yeah, the personal touch.
我们喜欢在一般性问题中提出特定于剧集的问题，剧集中关于剧集的一般问题，但是您可以留给我们的信件或语音注释，就像，是的，个人风格。
We are so moved hearing those stories, right?
听到这些故事我们很感动，对吗？
Josh, that's like our favorite.
乔什，这就像我们最喜欢的。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, a lot of people, there's a lot of like romantic connections people make when they realize someone is a how I met your mother fan and then they immediately have something to kind of connect on, there's people who were going through really hard times and how I met your mother was like their one, their lone source of kind of comfort and laughter or during really hard life transitions and things, you know, parents getting sick or relationships ending or all kinds of things.
我的意思是，很多人，当人们意识到某人是我如何认识你母亲的粉丝时，他们会立即建立起某种联系，有些人正在经历非常困难的时期，而我如何遇见你母亲就像他们的那样，是他们唯一的安慰和欢笑来源，或者在非常艰难的生活转变和事情中，你知道，父母生病或关系结束或各种各样的事情。
So, you know, we love the big comedy moments of How I Make Mother, we talk about them, we laugh about them, but we also honor that in addition to how hilarious How I Make Mother is, it really breaks your heart, makes you cry every third or fourth episode.
所以，你知道，我们喜欢《我如何做母亲》中的大喜剧时刻，我们谈论它们，我们嘲笑它们，但我们也很荣幸，除了《我如何做母亲》有多搞笑之外，它真的让你心碎，每三到四集就会让你哭泣。
So, we also want to honor that that's kind of part of the emotional connection people have with the show, you know?
所以，我们也想尊重这是人们与节目之间情感联系的一部分，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That's our favorite part to hear about.
这是我们最喜欢听到的部分。
Yeah, Craig, do you think you and I are gonna be able to have dinner tomorrow night?
是的，克雷格，你认为你和我明天晚上能吃晚饭吗？
We have a dinner schedule, I just wanna check.
我们有晚餐时间表，我只是想查一下。
I was worried that I was waking up a little congested, and I know there's a young one in your home now, so I'm taking that for seriously.
我担心我醒来时有点鼻塞，而且我知道你家里现在有一个小孩子，所以我认真对待这一点。
Can we clarify that that's a child of mine and not some weird thing that's going on?
我们能澄清一下，那是我的孩子，而不是发生了一些奇怪的事情吗？
By the way, yes, we have to clarify that.
顺便说一句，是的，我们必须澄清这一点。
We have to clarify that.
我们必须澄清这一点。
It's exactly the moment where we need to clarify that in American history.
这正是我们需要在美国历史上澄清这一点的时刻。
the baby that you have created with your wife is in your house.
你和你妻子创造的孩子就在你家里。
And so I will update you with anything changes, but I'm feeling okay.
所以我会向您通报任何变化，但我感觉还不错。
I appreciate you trying to keep my house safe.
我很感谢你努力保护我的房子的安全。
We just got through our first bout of sickness in the house.
我们刚刚度过了家里的第一场病痛。
I know, you guys were out of that.
我知道，你们已经不在了。
No fun.
没有乐趣。
That's why I would never forgive myself if I introduced a new cold interior.
这就是为什么如果我引入一个新的冰冷的内饰，我永远不会原谅自己。
Did Jordana get it too eventually?
乔丹娜最终也得到了它吗？
She did not.
她没有。
Just you, ah.
就你一个啊。
She did not, but me and the boy did.
她没有，但我和男孩做到了。
So, anyway, Alec, where are people tuning in from?
那么，Alec，人们从哪里收看节目呢？
What are we feeling, who's saying hi?
我们感觉如何，谁在打招呼？
They're definitely coming in from around the world.
他们肯定来自世界各地。
You caught me cold there, I don't have my list coming yet.
你让我感到很冷，我的名单还没来。
I don't know.
我不知道。
We are on a different app, so we're not seeing all the questions.
我们使用的是不同的应用程序，因此我们看不到所有问题。
Craig and I, Alec and Catherine are filtering them for us.
克雷格和我、亚历克和凯瑟琳正在为我们过滤它们。
And we should say this, we did this at noon today, hoping we would reach some people in some different time zones.
我们应该这么说，我们今天中午这样做了，希望我们能接触到一些不同时区的人。
The other couple of IG lives we've done have been at 8 p.m.
我们的另外几场 IG 直播是在晚上 8 点。
Eastern Standard Time, New York Time.
东部标准时间，纽约时间。
Only European Insomniacs could tune into that.
只有欧洲失眠症患者才能理解这一点。
So we got some very, very interesting questions.
所以我们得到了一些非常非常有趣的问题。
Right.
正确的。
All right.
好的。
I can give you a love from Germany and watching from the Philippines and bonjour de la France.
我可以给你来自德国的爱、来自菲律宾的观看以及法国的你好。
And many people just testing my knowledge by texting flag emojis.
许多人只是通过发送旗帜表情符号短信来测试我的知识。
You're going to fail that.
你会失败的。
And they pop up so tiny or squinting in a flag.
它们突然出现在旗帜中，显得那么小，或者眯着眼睛。
You gotta screenshot it, then blow it up and then, yeah.
你得把它截图，然后把它炸掉，然后，是的。
Okay, we have a couple of indias and Brazil and Romania and Georgia, don't know which one, but Georgia, Ecuador, Iowa, Italy, oh my goodness, they are coming in here.
好吧，我们有几个印度、巴西、罗马尼亚和格鲁吉亚，不知道是哪一个，但是格鲁吉亚、厄瓜多尔、爱荷华州、意大利，天哪，他们都来这里了。
So, Iran, Utah, love to the people of Iran, yes, amazing.
所以，伊朗，犹他州，对伊朗人民的爱，是的，令人惊叹。
Well, questions are pouring in, please folks, do send us your questions now, we actually have Josh and we actually have Craig right here to answer them for you.
好吧，问题纷至沓来，请大家现在就把你们的问题发给我们，我们实际上有乔希，我们实际上有克雷格在这里为你们解答。
Josh, several people are a little concerned with the fact that you now seem to be in a closet rather than in a living room and they're just simply asking, where is Josh?
乔希，有几个人有点担心你现在似乎在壁橱里而不是在客厅里，他们只是简单地问，乔希在哪里？
Yeah.
是的。
This is my wife's office.
这是我妻子的办公室。
There's a like a kind of therapist chair here.
这里有一把类似治疗师的椅子。
It's bigger.
它更大了。
I think then is I'm not in a I'm very claustrophobic.
我想我并没有处于一个非常幽闭恐惧症的状态。
I would not be in a do well in a closet.
我不会在壁橱里过得很好。
So, I'm in my wife's office, but the house is a little full today.
所以，我在我妻子的办公室，但今天房子有点满。
There's a lot buzzing around.
周围有很多嗡嗡声。
So this was my only private space, but thank you for your concern.
所以这是我唯一的私人空间，不过谢谢你的关心。
Reporting in New York City.
在纽约市报道。
And in New York City, that is a spacious office, by the way.
顺便说一句，在纽约市，那是一间宽敞的办公室。
Yeah.
是的。
Whatever.
任何。
What did I saw some tweets that said, people in New York City be like, you want to come over tonight and sit in my other chair?
我看到一些推文说，纽约市的人们是什么样的，你今晚想过来坐在我的另一张椅子上吗？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
Yeah, the How I Met Your Mother apartment, not as egregious as friends but still unrealistically big for you, probably.
是的，《老爸老妈的浪漫史》公寓，不像《朋友》那样令人震惊，但对你来说可能仍然大得不切实际。
Well you got it right with Lily's apartment when she had the high, the wall bed, or the vertical.
好吧，莉莉的公寓有高床、壁床或立式床，你就对了。
Way more accurate.
更准确。
That is way wildly more accurate.
这要准确得多。
You know a lot of people, I mean this is maybe like inside her showbiz, but the reason it's really hard to do honest New York apartments is because you have to fit a whole camera crew in there.
你认识很多人，我的意思是这可能就像在她的演艺圈里一样，但在纽约的公寓里做诚实的公寓真的很难，因为你必须在那里安置整个摄制组。
It's so hard to shoot.
拍起来太难了
It's really hard to shoot.
确实很难拍。
Yeah, that's why we basically tried to make it smaller than friends.
是的，这就是为什么我们基本上试图让它比朋友更小。
We were just like, we were just like, this is how to see balls.
我们就像，我们就像，这就是看球的方式。
And friends has been yelled out about this for our entire adult lives.
在我们整个成年生活中，朋友们一直为此大喊大叫。
Can we not, let's not be egregious.
我们能不能，我们不要太过分了。
But also it wasn't friends downtown and you guys are up, we were up our west side.
但也不是市中心的朋友，你们在上，我们在西边。
This was up our west.
这是我们的西部。
Yeah.
是的。
So it was a little bit of a, it was easier to go smaller in that regard.
所以它有点小，在这方面更容易变小。
And I think friends always said like it was like their aunt's apartment or so there was some like way they tried to speak to it.
我想朋友们总是说这就像他们姑妈的公寓，或者他们试图以某种类似的方式与之交谈。
But it was, you could, you could lend a plane in that part.
但那是，你可以，你可以在那部分借一架飞机。
It was gigantic.
它是巨大的。
And Tana Marshall, we were like, let's not make it like, it can't be perfect.
塔纳·马歇尔（Tana Marshall），我们当时想，我们不要让它变得完美，它不可能是完美的。
It has to be a little dark.
它必须有点暗。
In season two, we actually brightened up the paint a little bit because we thought we made it too dark.
在第二季中，我们实际上稍微提亮了油漆，因为我们认为我们把它做得太暗了。
In season one, at the end of season one, someone was like, maybe the network.
在第一季中，在第一季结束时，有人说，也许是网络。
They're like, it's a little drab of that apartment.
他们说，那间公寓有点单调。
But it's real.
但这是真实的。
And they're like, let's get more ratings.
他们说，让我们获得更多收视率。
We didn't notice that the couch switches from season one to season two, but it's a direct pickup.
我们没有注意到沙发从第一季切换到第二季，但它是直接拾取的。
Yeah.
是的。
So they like come in from like literally going downstairs and they come back and there's a new couch no one comments on it no one comments on it except the fans who now you know go episode episode quickly so they catch it they got a couch delivery in the brief four minutes well Marshall was crying on the stoop with that's the problem with someone brought in a new couch Marshall was actually he was actually crying because he missed the old couch well they put out on the Bermuda Triangle in front of the apartment which we we got to later and It disappears like that.
所以他们喜欢从楼下进来，然后他们回来了，有一张新沙发，没有人评论，除了那些现在你知道的粉丝，没有人评论，所以他们抓住了，他们在短短的四分钟内就得到了一张沙发。马歇尔在门廊上哭了，这就是有人带来了新沙发的问题。马歇尔实际上是在哭，因为他很想念旧沙发，他们把它放在百慕大三角的公寓前面，我们稍后到达，就这样消失了。
So it all really breaks.
所以这一切真的都破裂了。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了在纽约为你唱歌。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目。
All right.
好的。
We could shout out Turkey and Argentina and Netherlands and Albania and Mexico.
我们可以大声喊出土耳其、阿根廷、荷兰、阿尔巴尼亚和墨西哥。
Amazing here.
这里太棒了。
Craig, here's one for you.
克雷格，这是给你的。
How do you feel about the Late Show franchise ending?
您对深夜秀系列的结局有何看法？
About the Late Show franchise about, oh my God, I feel terrible about it.
关于《深夜秀》系列，天啊，我感觉很糟糕。
Tell us a little about why this question was directed at it.
告诉我们为什么这个问题是针对它的。
Yeah, okay, let me, yes.
是的，好吧，让我，是的。
That's why it took me a second because it was like, what's my right?
这就是为什么我花了一秒钟的时间，因为我想，我的权利是什么？
I am Carter Bayes and I used to write for Late Show with David Letterman, the host before Stephen Colbert, who Carter and I grew up in the 80s, idolizing Dave.
我是卡特·贝叶斯，我曾经为《大卫·莱特曼深夜秀》撰稿，他是史蒂芬·科尔伯特之前的主持人，卡特和我在 80 年代长大，崇拜戴夫。
We had a really crazy late night show on at 1230 on NBC.
我们在 NBC 1230 观看了一场非常疯狂的深夜节目。
That was like a mad scientist comedy lab.
那就像一个疯狂科学家喜剧实验室。
And then it moved to, while we were in college, he moved to more, led the 1130 slot, a bigger audience, and CBS, and the show became a little less insane, but still great, Dave's a legend.
然后事情转移到了，当我们上大学的时候，他转移到了更多，领导了 1130 时段，更多的观众和哥伦比亚广播公司，节目变得不那么疯狂了，但仍然很棒，戴夫是一个传奇。
We were 22, and we got hired to write for Dave Letterman.
我们当时 22 岁，受聘为戴夫·莱特曼 (Dave Letterman) 写作。
It was amazing.
太棒了。
And so we took a lot of pride.
所以我们感到非常自豪。
We were there four and a half years.
我们在那里呆了四年半。
It launched our entire career, changed our life completely.
它开启了我们的整个职业生涯，彻底改变了我们的生活。
Thank you, Dave, and everybody that worked there.
谢谢戴夫和在那里工作的每个人。
And then Dave passed it off to Stephen Colbert, and the idea that that franchise is ending, perhaps with a bunch of asterisks attached to it that have to do with free speech and things we won't get super political about on our IG live, it's sad to me.
然后戴夫把它传给了史蒂芬·科尔伯特，这个特许经营权即将结束的想法，也许附加了一堆星号，这些星号与言论自由以及我们不会在 IG 直播中过度政治化的事情有关，这对我来说很伤心。
Why is that show going away?
为什么这部剧要消失了？
What are the forces behind that?
这背后的力量是什么？
Comedy needs to survive.
喜剧需要生存。
We need a climate where people can tell the truth through comedy, that's what comedy is there for, that's why we have free speech.
我们需要一种人们可以通过喜剧讲述真相的氛围，这就是喜剧的用途，这就是我们拥有言论自由的原因。
If there's any part of that show going off the air that's related to these issues, which a lot of people think is the case that that bums me out even more than just it bums me out.
如果该节目中有任何与这些问题相关的部分被停播，很多人认为这会让我感到沮丧，这不仅仅是让我感到沮丧。
The idea of the institution of the late, the late show that I worked for going away, you walk past that spot in Midtown.
我为之工作的晚会机构的想法消失了，你走过中城的那个地方。
I spent, Carter and I spent almost five years exactly in that spot on 53rd and Broadway.
我和卡特在 53 号和百老汇的那个地方度过了将近五年。
The big marquee, the writer's office is up above it.
巨大的帐篷，作家的办公室就在上面。
It's an institution.
这是一个机构。
There's something cool about almost like, it's like your college going out of business.
有一些很酷的事情，就像你的大学倒闭了一样。
That's what this feels like.
这就是这种感觉。
It feels like your university.
感觉就像你的大学。
going to go to the spot where your college campus wasn't just gone.
要去一个你的大学校园不曾消失的地方。
And that was our kind of our comedy grad school.
这就是我们的喜剧研究生院。
And I every time I walk by the Colbert League show, I smile because I remember I'm happy there's still that show, a version of that show happening there.
每次我路过科尔伯特联盟演出时，我都会微笑，因为我记得我很高兴仍然有那个节目，那个节目的一个版本在那里上演。
And yeah, I feel sad.
是的，我感到难过。
I feel sad about it going away.
我对它的消失感到难过。
And also without you guys having written for David Letterman, there's no how I may or mother.
而且，如果没有你们为大卫·莱特曼写信，我和妈妈就无法做到这一点。
I mean, it's a direct line from Wesleyan to Letterman to stage 22 on the Fox lot and how I met your mother a straight line there's no world how I met your mother would have happened without us being in that spot for four and a half years around the block from McGee's the how I met your mother bar where the bartender hopefully will now know we have a podcast yeah if you're just joining us closer Craig and I host a podcast we're re-watching how I met your mother from the start please join us it's called how we made your mother William, we call it, and you can just go to howwemadeyourmother.com and it'll direct you to all sorts of options for listening to the podcast on however you like to listen to podcasts.
我的意思是，这是从卫斯理安到莱特曼到福克斯停车场第 22 阶段的直达线路，我是如何遇见你母亲的，如果不是我们在麦吉附近的街区呆了四年半，我是如何遇见你母亲的，根本不可能发生。从一开始就认识了你的母亲，请加入我们，这就是我们如何造就你的母亲威廉，我们称之为，你可以访问 howwemadeyourmother.com，它会引导你找到各种收听播客的选项，无论你喜欢听什么播客。
Patrick Felton W asks a very timely question, which is, I realize now by the time the rest of the world hears this Instagram live, this Instagram live where you are all asking us questions now will appear as a podcast in a couple of months, but he'd like to know about the proposal that started out just this week's episode and says, have you had a message of how the proposal worked out on the last episode of Quimium, and all I can announce is that for those listening live, yes, and stay tuned in just a couple of episodes where you're going to hear the outcome of that wedding proposal.
Patrick Felton W 提出了一个非常及时的问题，也就是说，我现在意识到，当世界其他地方听到这个 Instagram 直播时，这个你们现在都在向我们提问的 Instagram 直播将在几个月后以播客的形式出现，但他想了解本周节目中开始的提案，并说，你们是否收到了 Quimium 最后一集提案如何实施的消息，我所能宣布的是，对于那些现场收听的人，是的，请继续关注在几集里你会听到求婚的结果。
We just got some news this very morning with with some photos attached to it.
今天早上我们刚刚收到一些消息，并附有一些照片。
So that's good.
所以这样很好。
I've been on a TV show, how I met your mother, where there was an actual proposal.
我参加过一个电视节目，讲述我是如何认识你母亲的，其中有一个实际的求婚。
Oh yeah, that's right.
哦，是的，没错。
I've had three, maybe four proposals at music venues where I've been playing shows.
我在我表演过的音乐场所收到了三个，也许四个提案。
Wait, that you've been proposed to or someone else?
等等，有人向你或其他人求婚了？
I've gotten a couple of those.
我已经得到了其中几个。
But no, people, you know, ask, you know, they're gonna propose at the show.
但不，人们，你知道，问，你知道，他们会在演出上求婚。
I brought one couple up on stage.
我带一对夫妇上台。
Actually in Buenos Aires, No, not in Buenos Aires, sorry.
实际上是在布宜诺斯艾利斯，不，不是在布宜诺斯艾利斯，抱歉。
In Sao Paulo, when I was playing with Ben Lee, we had a proposal on stage.
在圣保罗，当我和本·李（Ben Lee）一起演奏时，我们在舞台上求婚了。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
And then now in the podcast, like in this podcast.
然后现在在播客中，就像在这个播客中一样。
So, yeah.
所以，是的。
So if you stick with me, folks, if you're looking to partner off, I would clearly.
所以，如果你们坚持我，伙计们，如果你们想合作，我显然会的。
That's in this week's episode, right?
这是本周的剧集，对吧？
The one that's out right now, the Monday Night Football episode, right?
现在正在播出的《周一橄榄球之夜》剧集，对吧？
That episode begins with a fan message that ends with a proposal.
该集以粉丝留言开始，以求婚结束。
And yes, so stay tuned, tune in, and you will hear the answer to everything about that.
是的，所以请继续关注，收听，您将听到有关这一切的答案。
We were blown away.
我们被震撼了。
And Alec is a very, Alec, you're very clever.
亚历克是一个非常，亚历克，你非常聪明。
You like springing things on Josh.
你喜欢乔希身上的东西。
You don't always tell us about what do you have up your sleeve when we're recording the podcast.
当我们录制播客时，您并不总是告诉我们您有什么秘密。
You blew our minds with that.
你让我们大吃一惊。
So yeah, tune in and we won't get up to it.
所以，是的，请收听，我们不会这么做。
We often haven't heard the audio message, nor have we, I mean, you sometimes send this C-block letter over to us, but most of the time we're reading it cold, which actually I think really helps us respond pretty authentically in the moment.
我们经常没有听到音频消息，我的意思是，您有时会向我们发送这封 C 块信件，但大多数时候我们只是冷读它，实际上我认为这确实有助于我们在当下做出非常真实的回应。
You know, yeah.
你知道，是的。
Right.
正确的。
None of that has anything to do with the fact that I haven't prepared until about one hour before the show starts.
这一切与我直到演出开始前大约一小时才准备的事实无关。
I thought I was letting you off the hook, man.
我以为我让你摆脱了困境，伙计。
I was kidding.
我开玩笑的。
I'll edit this part out.
我会把这部分编辑掉。
You do it from yourself under the bus.
你可以在公交车下自己做。
You're the guy that can edit that out.
你就是那个可以编辑它的人。
You're the guy.
你就是那个家伙。
You can make yourself yourself.
你可以做你自己。
No editing.
没有编辑。
A couple of just lovely notes here that we're getting here.
我们在这里得到了一些可爱的注释。
Anna.gi.
安娜吉。
I says, you maybe love your character, Josh so much.
我说，你可能非常喜欢你的角色，乔什。
I named my baby after him.
我以他的名字给我的孩子命名。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Evelyn.
伊芙琳。
Ahh.
啊。
Dr. Axe.
斧头博士。
Baby Dr. Axe.
宝贝斧头博士。
My baby Dr. Axe.
我的宝贝阿克斯博士。
Here's one where, I mean, you guys, obviously, over the decades now, I've heard so many of these kinds of comments.
我的意思是，很明显，你们这些人，几十年来，我听过很多这样的评论。
But I know that on the show, often you'll slow down and you'll go, hey, you know, when we sat down to do this show, did we ever imagine?
但我知道在节目中，你常常会放慢脚步，然后你会说，嘿，你知道，当我们坐下来做这个节目时，我们有没有想象过？
So just real basic.
所以只是真正的基本。
It, Melita says, we raised our kids and taught them life lessons from the show.
梅丽塔说，我们抚养了我们的孩子，并从节目中教给他们人生课程。
I mean, was that ever something, Craig?
我的意思是，克雷格，有这样的事吗？
Your card is sitting around, drumming up your pilot here.
你的卡片就在附近，在这里鼓动你的飞行员。
Could you imagine that this is, that it, Melita, two decades later, are gonna raise their kids and teach them life off to the shit that you saw.
你能想象吗，二十年后，梅利塔将抚养他们的孩子，教他们如何生活，就像你所看到的那样。
I'm still dealing with how old that makes us.
我仍在思考我们的年龄。
I'm not over with us being super old part.
我还没有结束我们的超级老生活。
When that wave of nausea passes, I'll be able to appreciate this more.
当那股恶心过去时，我将能够更加欣赏这一点。
But it's like you and Carter are like the new Dr. Spock.
但这就像你和卡特就像新的斯波克博士。
He's teaching a generation how to parent their children.
他正在教导一代人如何养育孩子。
Yes, yes, that's exactly what we thought we were up to when we were drinking at McGee's around the corner from Letterman in 1999.
是的，是的，这正是 1999 年我们在莱特曼街角的麦吉酒吧喝酒时所想的。
And we're like, someday kids will be taught by whatever bullshit we're coming up with.
我们就像，有一天孩子们会被我们想出的任何废话所教导。
Yeah, and no, it's stunning, it's stunning.
是的，不，这太令人惊叹了，太令人惊叹了。
Well, also Craig, you know, we talked, especially in first season about, that you guys were 29 when you started writing this show, right?
嗯，还有克雷格，你知道，我们谈过，尤其是在第一季，你们开始写这个节目时才 29 岁，对吧？
29 to 38.
29 至 38。
But you were writing this older man's voice who was 20, 25 years older than you.
但你写的是这个比你大20、25岁的老人的声音。
But you had to imagine a kind of wiser, older version of yourself to write that part, right?
但你必须想象一个更聪明、更老的自己来写那部分，对吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So I remember you said, and maybe Carter said this when he was on, but you guys were kind of trying to write a comforting voice for yourself, like imagining what would you want to hear your older self say about these years?
所以我记得你说过，也许卡特在上场时说过这句话，但你们有点想为自己写一个安慰的声音，就像想象一下，你想听到年长的自己对这些年说些什么？
Yeah.
是的。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
That 100%.
那个100%。
playing wisdom.
发挥智慧。
And we were like, it's fake until you make it.
我们当时想，在你成功之前它都是假的。
How do I hope I'll look at this time?
我希望这次我会怎么看？
How does younger me hope older me will frame this and make sense of this?
年轻的我希望年长的我如何构建这个框架并理解它？
And again, I know I've said this before, but like we missed New York so much.
再说一遍，我知道我以前说过这句话，但就像我们非常想念纽约一样。
We did our 20s in New York, writing for Dave Letterman.
我们二十多岁时在纽约为戴夫·莱特曼写作。
We moved to LA, did how much her mother, and we missed New York.
我们搬到了洛杉矶，照顾了她的母亲，我们想念纽约。
The second the planes wheels set down in Los Angeles, I'll do respect to Los Angeles, we missed New York terribly.
飞机在洛杉矶降落的那一刻，我向洛杉矶表示敬意，我们非常想念纽约。
9-11 had happened not that long before our move.
9·11事件发生在我们搬家前不久。
And I feel like we missed a New York that was like before that horrible tragedy.
我觉得我们错过了那个可怕悲剧发生之前的纽约。
And like something about that sequence of events and these huge leaps we were taking in life and a leap away from a really hard time for New York City, it all colored how we wanted to look back.
就像这一系列事件以及我们在生活中所取得的巨大飞跃以及摆脱纽约市真正困难时期的飞跃一样，这一切都影响了我们回顾过去的方式。
We began looking back at a very young age because it felt like a chapter had ended at that moment.
我们开始回顾很小的时候，因为那一刻感觉好像一个章节已经结束了。
we moved in 2002 to Los Angeles, like six months after 9-11.
2002 年，也就是 9-11 事件发生六个月后，我们搬到了洛杉矶。
And I think that really, there's something about that moment in time that informed the idea of how will we look back from the future at now.
我认为，确实，那一刻的某些东西告诉了我们现在将如何回顾未来。
And I think that injected something into a mid-term other that might not have been there otherwise.
我认为这为中期其他项目注入了一些原本可能不会存在的东西。
We have M.
我们有M。
Beth, G78 just wants us to know that her sister's apartment in Queens is 500 square feet.
Beth，G78 只是想让我们知道她姐姐在皇后区的公寓有 500 平方英尺。
There's a lot smaller than that one, too.
还有比那个小很多的。
Benny, I believe it's just thank you for your music, Josh.
本尼，我相信这只是感谢你的音乐，乔什。
It really means so much more to people than you think and greetings from Germany.
来自德国的问候对人们来说真的比你想象的意义要大得多。
Oh, that's so kind of you.
哦，你真是太好了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah, I feel like, Josh, first of all, Josh does the theme song of this podcast.
是的，我觉得，乔什，首先，乔什创作了这个播客的主题曲。
That's Josh's song, NYC.
这是乔什的歌，纽约。
And yeah, for anybody that's like new to the podcast and maybe new to the idea that Josh does music, go look him up on Apple Music.
是的，对于那些刚接触播客或者对 Josh 做音乐的想法不熟悉的人来说，可以去 Apple Music 上查找他。
They'll look him up on Spotify.
他们会在 Spotify 上查找他。
It's just gem after gem after gem, brilliant melodies, brilliant lyrics.
它只是一颗又一颗的宝石，美妙的旋律，美妙的歌词。
And this guy didn't pick up a guitar to how much the mother ended.
而这家伙却没有拿起吉他到妈妈结束的程度。
It's unbelievable what you did in that span of time to arrive at the place where you're the songwriter and singer that you are.
令人难以置信的是，你在那段时间里所做的一切，让你成为了歌曲作者和歌手。
It's really great.
真的很棒。
I'm not just saying that.
我不只是这么说。
Everybody needs to go look that up right now, if you have it.
如果你有的话，每个人都需要立即去查找。
That's so kind of you, Craig.
你真是太好了，克雷格。
I would also like to make a pitch for doing something that you think you're too old to do that you always have the sense that you want to do.
我还想倡导做一些你认为自己太老而不能做但你总是有自己想做的事情。
And, you know, I always, you know, I was an obsessive music fan along with Carter and Craig.
而且，你知道，我一直是一个与卡特和克雷格一样痴迷的音乐迷。
I recommended a lot of songs and bands that got onto the show.
我推荐了很多出现在节目中的歌曲和乐队。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
And, but I always, whenever I would watch music, it was almost like I loved it so much that I felt like I could do it.
而且，但我总是，每当我看音乐时，就好像我非常喜欢它，以至于我觉得我能做到。
And then I started writing songs with my friend, Ben Lee.
然后我开始和我的朋友本·李一起写歌。
And now, and I started playing guitar basically at 40, 41 maybe.
现在，我基本上是在 40、41 岁的时候开始弹吉他的。
And it's just been such a joy in my life to pick it up later.
后来捡起它真是我生命中的一大乐趣。
And I think I had this idea that you had to start it when you were 12, 15, have the band and your parents garage.
我想我有一个想法，你必须在 12、15 岁的时候开始，拥有乐队和父母的车库。
And I just did it in a different way.
我只是以不同的方式做到了。
And it's just been a real source of joy in my life.
这是我生活中真正的快乐源泉。
So thank you for that, Craig.
谢谢你，克雷格。
Oh, I mean, you're legitimately really good at it.
哦，我的意思是，你真的很擅长。
It's really great that you picked this extra artistic tool up and you didn't decide for no reason, right?
你选择了这个额外的艺术工具，而且不是无缘无故地做出决定，这真的很棒，对吧？
We all talk ourselves out of shit.
我们都劝自己不要再胡闹了。
I'm too old to do this.
我太老了，做不了这件事。
No, you're great at it.
不，你很擅长。
You picked it up at 40 and you're amazing.
你在 40 岁的时候就学会了它，你太棒了。
I'm so good at it that Jenna Fisher retroactively thought I was playing guitar in 2006, when she did the reading at my house.
我太擅长弹吉他了，2006 年，珍娜·费舍尔 (Jenna Fisher) 在我家读书时，还以为我在弹吉他。
But I was not.
但我不是。
I go backwards in time.
我回到过去。
Little shout out to Ben Lee.
向本·李大声喊叫。
I don't know if I've ever even told you this, Josh.
我不知道我是否曾告诉过你这一点，乔什。
Stop me if I have, or don't, because we'll just talk and this will be content for Alec to monetize later.
如果我有或没有，请阻止我，因为我们只是谈谈，这将满足亚历克稍后的货币化。
But, Ben Lee, at the end of season one of How Much Mother, the show is a baby show.
但是，本·李，在《多少妈妈》第一季结束时，该剧是一部婴儿剧。
I think we were launching a season two, somewhere in between, because I remember the office we were in when we got this phone call.
我认为我们正在推出第二季，介于两者之间，因为我记得接到这个电话时我们所在的办公室。
It was the season, we moved into, we must have been launching season two, the phone rings, and it's our assistant, and they go, it's Ben Lee calling from Australia.
那是我们搬进的季节，我们一定是在推出第二季，电话铃响了，是我们的助理打来的，然后他们就走了，是本·李从澳大利亚打来的。
We go, what?
我们走，什么？
We don't know, Ben Lee.
我们不知道，本·李。
He's great.
他很棒。
We're fans of him.
我们是他的粉丝。
And he was cool, and we didn't know him.
他很酷，但我们不认识他。
And they were like, are you sure Ben Lee is calling for us?
他们说，你确定本·李在打电话给我们吗？
Is there some other extension here on the Fox lot?
福克斯地段还有其他扩建吗？
He might rather talk to than us.
他可能更愿意和我们说话。
Like, no, he's calling for you.
就像，不，他在呼唤你。
And we got on the phone and he just goes, I just wanted to tell you how much mother is kind of hitting right now in Australia and we're loving it.
我们通了电话，他就说，我只是想告诉你，妈妈现在在澳大利亚有多受打击，我们很喜欢这样。
I'm loving this show so much.
我非常喜欢这个节目。
It really speaks to me.
这真的很适合我。
The tone of it, the heart of it, the music of it.
它的基调，它的核心，它的音乐。
He didn't know you yet.
他还不认识你。
I don't think Josh.
我不认为乔什。
This is 20 years ago, this story.
这是20年前的故事了。
Well, I mean, he just reached out.
嗯，我是说，他刚刚伸出手来。
And I remember it's slightly different.
我记得略有不同。
Did you guys try to get a song of his and his label, I think he was maybe with Warner Brothers at the time, like his label like priced him out.
你们有没有尝试获取他和他的唱片公司的歌曲，我想他当时可能在华纳兄弟，就像他的唱片公司一样把他定价过高。
Like you guys couldn't afford the song.
就像你们买不起这首歌一样。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
I don't remember that.
And I'll check with Ben.
我会和本核实一下。
But I thought- I think he cold called us.
但我想——我想他冷冷地给我们打了电话。
I don't think he cold called you to say I'm sorry they didn't give you that song if they had asked me.
我不认为他冷冷地打电话给你是为了说对不起，如果他们问了我，他们没有给你那首歌。
Oh maybe.
哦，也许吧。
I would have told them to give it to you.
我会告诉他们把它给你。
And then you guys invited him to set, right?
然后你们就邀请他来现场，对吗？
When he was back in L.S.
当他回到 L.S.
Yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的。
You come to set and like just see how we made the show.
你来片场只是想看看我们是如何制作这个节目的。
Yeah.
是的。
And that's when I met him.
就在那时我遇见了他。
And that's the whole reason I'm a songwriter just because I became friends with Ben and we started writing songs together.
这就是我成为一名词曲作者的全部原因，只是因为我和本成为了朋友，我们开始一起写歌。
Isn't that crazy?
这不是疯了吗？
So he cold calls because he just, how much mother spoke to him in some way?
所以他突然打电话是因为他只是，母亲以某种方式对他说了多少话？
And somehow that outcome leads to you two in Brazil and someone's proposing in Brazil because Ben Lee cold called our office at the first season too.
不知何故，这个结果导致你们两个在巴西，有人在巴西求婚，因为本·李在第一季也冷酷地打电话给我们的办公室。
That's fucking crazy, right?
这太他妈疯狂了，对吧？
I know.
我知道。
I'm so glad I ate so many gummies right before we started this because this is hitting me so.
我很高兴在我们开始之前吃了这么多软糖，因为这对我来说太打击了。
You always wanted to hit it at the 26 minute mark of the Instagram live.
你总是想在 Instagram 直播的 26 分钟时击中它。
It's just right when you want to be.
当你想要的时候，它就是正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
J.D.
Shaiman is just shouting us all out here.
谢曼只是在这里对我们所有人大喊大叫。
He wants to say also look up the salads while you're looking up.
他想说的是，当你抬头时也看看沙拉。
That's right.
这是正确的。
And Radder and Lee.
还有雷德和李。
He also says, Alec, thank you for steering the quimium ship.
他还说，亚历克，谢谢你驾驶这艘奎姆船。
You're welcome.
不客气。
And I'll also say, by the way, just sort of side note to say this publicly as they say, that I remember very clearly when I was rehearsing, I was directing this one woman opera and I was in my mother's apartment and the woman who was the singer was sitting on a couch and my phone was in front of her and she rings and she goes, Josh Radner is calling you and I guess she didn't know that there was already connection.
顺便说一句，就像他们所说的那样，我还想公开说一下，我记得很清楚，当我排练时，我正在导演一部女歌剧，当时我在我母亲的公寓里，那位女歌手坐在沙发上，我的电话在她面前，她响了，她走了，乔什·拉德纳正在打电话给你，我猜她不知道已经接通了。
I was like, oh, that's even, no, Josh, we were friends.
我当时想，哦，那甚至，不，乔什，我们是朋友。
That was a rarity.
那是很少见的。
like that's not a big deal let it go to voicemail no but I I scurried over picked it up and very quickly you pitched doing this and asked me to come on board and to this day I am forever grateful for well I called I mean this is the this is the quickest podcast origin story in the world Jordan said I want to watch your show that I've never seen that was a decade of your life I called Craig should we do a podcast Craig said yeah of course let's call Alec we literally just called you yeah we added you into the call and you said yes and then oh wow we're doing it I didn't know that that was it was all on one call it was all launched on one call every every project you yeah think about happen as effortless amen amen yeah well thank you it's not the TV development process.
好像这没什么大不了的，让它转到语音信箱不，但我我赶紧过去接起来，很快你就开始做这件事并要求我加入，直到今天我永远感激我打电话我的意思是这是这是世界上最快的播客起源故事乔丹说我想看你的节目我从未见过那是你生命中的十年我给克雷格打电话我们应该做一个播客克雷格说是的当然让我们打电话给亚历克我们真的刚刚给你打了电话，是的，我们把你加入到通话中，你说是，然后哦，哇，我们正在做，我不知道那是一次通话，所有你想到的每个项目都通过一次通话启动，毫不费力地发生，阿门阿门是的，谢谢你，这不是电视开发过程。
This is the brilliant thing about podcasts.
这就是播客的精彩之处。
You just fucking do it.
你他妈的就是这么做。
I mean, you know, I don't know how much you'll have to say about this, but JIC 2012 probably speaks for many who asked, what do you guys think of Jason and Kobe getting together on shrinking?
我的意思是，你知道，我不知道你对此有多少要说的，但 JIC 2012 可能代表了许多人的疑问，你们对杰森和科比在缩小尺寸问题上的合作有何看法？
What a wild connection that is.
这是多么狂野的联系啊。
So Kobe is on shrinking and Jason's daughter, Jason's character's daughter is trying to get into Wesleyan on shrinking.
所以科比正在收缩，杰森的女儿，杰森角色的女儿正试图进入卫斯理安收缩。
It's like, yes, the computer The theater simulation that runs life is running out of ideas and just recycling ingredients now.
就像，是的，运行生活的计算机模拟剧院已经耗尽了想法，现在只能回收成分。
No, it's cool.
不，这很酷。
It's very cool.
非常酷。
It's very cool to see them together.
看到他们在一起真是太酷了。
And it just feels like something comforting to my videos.
这对我的视频来说就像是一种安慰。
What I was thinking about when I kept seeing previews for it, I was like in the kind of constellation, so you have these five characters and how I met your mother.
当我不断看到它的预览时，我在想什么，我就像在那种星座中，所以你有这五个角色以及我是如何遇见你母亲的。
So like me and Barney had a ton of stuff.
就像我和巴尼一样，有很多东西。
Me and Marshall had a ton of stuff.
我和马歇尔有很多东西。
Me and Lily had a ton of stuff.
我和莉莉有很多东西。
Lily and Robin had a ton of stuff.
莉莉和罗宾有很多东西。
Lily and Barney had a ton of stuff.
莉莉和巴尼有很多东西。
Marshall and Barney had a ton of stuff.
马歇尔和巴尼有很多东西。
The two characters I would say that had the kind of least.
我想说这两个角色是最少的。
Definitely.
确实。
Were Marshall and Robin.
是马歇尔和罗宾。
Yeah, we missed a bet there.
是的，我们在那里错过了一个赌注。
Maybe we should have done more with them.
也许我们应该对他们做更多的事情。
They're great together.
他们在一起很棒。
But it's cool that they're now getting to work together in that way.
但他们现在以这种方式合作真是太酷了。
Not that they weren't set every day in the booth together at the same time.
并不是说他们不是每天都同时在展位上。
But there weren't road trip movies of the two of them too much.
但他们两人的公路旅行电影并不多。
There was one where they bonded over this Minnesota bar and they had a Canadian bar and a Minnesotan bar and feeling displacement.
他们在明尼苏达州的一家酒吧和一家加拿大酒吧和一家明尼苏达州酒吧建立了联系，并感到流离失所。
Did they also have like they were impervious to the cold together?
他们是不是也像在一起一样不畏严寒？
They were impervious to the cold.
他们不受寒冷影响。
Yeah, we found those little overlaps, but I do feel like we could have done more there.
是的，我们发现了一些小的重叠，但我确实觉得我们可以在那里做得更多。
So maybe the universe is evening it out now in some way.
所以也许宇宙现在正在以某种方式平衡它。
So thank you, Jason Segal, for doing that.
谢谢杰森·西格尔所做的一切。
Correcting that error on our part.
我们正在纠正该错误。
They're coming in here.
他们要进来了。
Here's one.
这是一个。
Are there, I mean, obviously our fans, your fans use, there are so many, so many lines, so many quotes that people use in their daily life.
我的意思是，显然我们的粉丝、你们的粉丝使用了很多、很多台词、很多人们在日常生活中使用的引言。
They tattoo them, they use them in their wedding proposals, and are there any quirks or callback jokes or lines that you find yourself using in real life?
他们纹身它们，他们在求婚中使用它们，你发现自己在现实生活中使用过任何怪癖或回调笑话或台词吗？
I mean, they must come up, but are you affected by him, him lines in your daily lives as the fans are?
我的意思是，他们一定会出现，但是你是否像粉丝一样受到他的影响，他在你日常生活中的台词？
I will say the major general runner is like impossible.
我会说，少将赛跑几乎是不可能的。
Once you have that in your head, once it's in, you know?
一旦你脑子里有了这个，一旦它进入了，你知道吗？
You cannot erase that one, like you can't eternal sunshine that out of your head.
你无法抹去它，就像你无法将永恒的阳光从你的脑海中抹去一样。
Yeah, we talked about this on the show, that I got a letter from a couple that were huge, how I met your mother, friends, and they were having a baby, and she was at the end of something like a 28, 36-hour labor.
是的，我们在节目中谈到了这一点，我收到了一封来自一对夫妇的来信，内容很重要，我是如何认识你的母亲和朋友的，他们正在生孩子，而她正在经历 28、36 小时的分娩。
And the OBGYN was delivering her baby.
妇产科医生正在接生她的孩子。
It was literally like, the baby's like almost, and she said, the OBGYN said, you know, push, you're having a major contraction, and she turned her husband, and she became the salute.
从字面上看，就像，婴儿几乎一样，她说，妇产科医生说，你知道，用力，你正在发生严重的宫缩，然后她转过身来向她的丈夫致敬，然后她就行了礼。
Right as her baby was being born.
就在她的孩子出生时。
We talked about this first season.
我们讨论了第一季。
Do you not remember this?
你不记得这个了吗？
You know you did, but it's blow my mind all over again.
你知道你做到了，但这再次让我大吃一惊。
Like that kind of thing is so funny.
好像这样的事情真是太好笑了。
Like when we hear things like that, we're just like, that's an unbelievable thing.
就像当我们听到这样的事情时，我们就像，这是一件令人难以置信的事情。
And also like that kid, that's part of his birth story forever and ever and ever.
也像那个孩子一样，这永远是他出生故事的一部分。
And again, to trace, I think our theme of this particular episode slash IG Live, whatever we're doing here, is the butterfly flaps its wings and then someone makes a major salute when a baby's being born.
再说一遍，我认为我们这一集斜线 IG Live 的主题，无论我们在这里做什么，都是蝴蝶扇动翅膀，然后在婴儿出生时有人行礼。
Like the chaos theory is like that is the theme of this episode of good cast.
就像混沌理论一样，这就是这一集好演员的主题。
Well, it also speaks to the theme that, do you know how like I accepted an invitation very casually in 2022 to join my friend Jacob out of thing?
嗯，它也谈到了这个主题，你知道我在 2022 年非常随意地接受了邀请，加入我的朋友雅各布吗？
And it's where I met my wife.
这是我遇见我妻子的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
But like the casualness with which I said yes to the invitation is I always look back on it It's like I didn't be like this is going to be a very momentous weekend in my life like and and yeah And in some ways I think like cuz we talk a lot about the like life philosophy on the show because the show itself is packed With life philosophies, but it's like this kind of idea.
但就像我对邀请说“是”时的随意一样，我总是回顾它，就像我觉得这不会是我生命中一个非常重要的周末，是的，在某些方面，我认为因为我们在节目中谈论了很多类似的生活哲学，因为节目本身充满了生活哲学，但它就像这样的想法。
Yeah, okay There's there's big struggles and setbacks and failures that actually get you maybe where you need to be.
是的，好吧，有一些巨大的挣扎、挫折和失败，实际上可能会让你到达你需要的地方。
But at the same time, a lot of life is just an accumulation of pretty casual moments that end up being very consequential.
但与此同时，生活中的很多事情只是一些非常偶然的时刻的积累，而这些时刻最终会产生非常重要的影响。
Only in retrospect.
只能回想起来。
Only in consequential, yeah, yeah.
只是结果而已，是啊，是啊。
Alec Lev is the originator of the major general colonel of truth salute.
亚历克·列夫是《真理致敬》少将上校的鼻祖。
And he and his friends did that in high school, right?
他和他的朋友在高中时就这么做了，对吗？
Maybe even earlier in that, Alec.
也许更早，亚历克。
And then I, you met me in college.
然后我，你在大学遇见了我。
I started doing it.
我开始这样做了。
Like Josh said, once it's in you, that's it.
就像乔什说的，一旦它在你体内，就是这样。
It's like a vaccine.
这就像疫苗一样。
It's just in your bloodstream forever.
它永远存在于你的血液中。
It's been ejected in you.
它已经被驱逐到你体内了。
And Craig, also one of the great comedy thieves of our life, our time.
还有克雷格，他也是我们这个时代、我们生活中最伟大的喜剧窃贼之一。
I have no problem stealing other people's material.
我可以毫无问题地窃取其他人的材料。
I've never seen it.
我从来没有见过它。
Be careful.
当心。
You say a funny thing around Craig.
你在克雷格周围说了一件有趣的事情。
It's gonna end up in a book for all of these stuff.
所有这些内容最终都会写成一本书。
I definitely did that to Alec.
我确实对亚历克这么做了。
I don't remember if I asked you permission.
我不记得我是否征求过你的许可。
Did I, Alec?
我是吗，亚历克？
I'm not.
我不是。
I think that that one I did.
我想我就是这么做的。
A lot of times I didn't.
很多时候我没有。
No, I think you knew that I was.
不，我想你知道我是。
I still miss from our lives.
我仍然想念我们的生活。
No, I think you knew that I would be overjoyed by the life.
不，我想你知道我会对这样的生活感到欣喜若狂。
I think I knew you would be overjoyed by the life.
我想我知道你会对这样的生活感到欣喜若狂。
Did Carter also know it?
卡特也知道吗？
Did Carter do it?
卡特做到了吗？
Yeah, I think we had Carter doing it too, because we all went to college together.
是的，我想卡特也这么做了，因为我们一起上大学。
How Carter, Alec, and I all went to Wesley and bring Wesley in back full circle.
卡特、亚历克和我是如何一起去找韦斯利并把韦斯利带回来的。
And we, yes, we're all doing that.
我们，是的，我们都在这样做。
And then we put it on the show.
然后我们把它放在节目中。
And now here it is, like, you know, during a birth story of someone's first moment in the world.
现在，就像，你知道，在某人来到世界的第一个时刻的出生故事中。
Do you know what I, it's not so much catch raises or runners, but there's certain things that I think about that I think are so smart.
你知道我吗，这并不是那么多的接球加注或跑动，而是我认为有些事情非常聪明。
And we haven't even gotten close to this episode.
我们甚至还没有接近这一集。
I don't know where this episode is.
我不知道这一集在哪里。
But the one where James Vanderbeek played Robin's like high school crush, like her boyfriend, right?
但詹姆斯·范德贝克扮演的罗宾就像是高中迷恋对象，就像她的男朋友，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
The idea that like, if you loved someone when you're 14, 15, 16, no matter what they become or how they look later in life, you will continue, your heart will pound when you see them.
这个想法就像，如果你在14、15、16岁时爱过一个人，无论他们变成什么样子，或者他们以后的生活如何，你都会继续下去，当你看到他们时，你的心会剧烈跳动。
You know, like they will continue to be the, and I just thought that was such a smart observation about youth and like first love and how, like there's certain things like that that come back to me.
你知道，就像他们将继续那样，我只是认为这是对青春和初恋的如此聪明的观察，以及如何，就像有某些类似的事情回到了我的身边。
And I think, God, that was smart.
我想，天哪，这太聪明了。
Yeah, my most recent thing like that, it's kind of the same theme, and I've, was it literally the same episode?
是的，我最近的类似的事情，它是相同的主题，而且我，它实际上是同一集吗？
Revert a go?
恢复一下？
Is that, was that in that episode?
是吗，是那一集里的吗？
Oh yeah, what was that?
哦，是的，那是什么？
What was that?
那是什么？
Senior moment.
高年级时刻。
The idea that old people from your past bring out a completely old version of you, it just comes back out, like Lily just, like completely reverts when this friend of hers comes from her past.
你过去的旧人带出了一个完全旧版本的你的想法，就像莉莉一样，当她的这个朋友来自她的过去时，它就完全恢复了。
I think it might have been that same episode.
我想这可能是同一集。
How many moment?
多少时刻？
Like we brought out something different in this head, yeah.
就像我们在这个头脑中带来了一些不同的东西，是的。
I thought of it recently because I've had a couple times, 50 now and I've had a couple of times where I hung out with people from my 20s and 30s.
我最近想到这个，因为我有过几次，现在已经50岁了，而且我也有过几次和20多岁、30多岁的人一起出去玩的经历。
I mean, went out and like had a big drinking night, a big drinking night is a lot less than it used to be for me, but it still like doesn't take much.
我的意思是，出去喝了一个大酒之夜，一个大酒之夜对我来说比以前少了很多，但仍然不需要太多。
And the way I felt sick for like 72 hours after like my revert ago, it was like, oh, well, party like we used to.
就像我之前回归后的 72 小时内，我感到不舒服，就像，哦，好吧，就像我们以前那样聚会。
Oh God, it's so bad.
天哪，这太糟糕了。
It's been hurt so much.
已经受了这么大的伤害了
And I remember in like a three day hangover after one of those nights, I thought it was revert ago.
我记得在其中一个晚上之后的三天宿醉中，我以为它已经恢复了。
The revert ago did me in.
之前的回归让我陷入了困境。
I acted like I just was 28 again, and guess what, I'm 50.
我表现得好像我又回到了 28 岁，你猜怎么着，我已经 50 岁了。
So that was my most recent hymiumism that came into my head.
这就是我最近脑海中浮现的赞美之情。
I was like, I should know better.
我当时想，我应该更了解。
Yeah.
是的。
And this old man, he busted me, fell in love with you, knew where you were sitting.
这个老人，他打败了我，爱上了你，知道你坐在哪里。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
of commercials, back to Shell.
广告，回到壳牌。
Sis- uh, sorry, Sis-a-li-sorrow says, I'm skipping class right now so I could watch this, so.
姐姐——呃，抱歉，悲伤姐姐说，我现在要逃课，所以我可以看这个，所以。
We approve.
我们同意。
We'll write you a note.
我们会给你写一张便条。
Okay, um, I'm gonna say that for the end.
好吧，嗯，我就这么说到最后。
Um, we've gone over this a little bit on the show, Craig, but I know people always are curious.
嗯，我们已经在节目中讨论过这个问题了，克雷格，但我知道人们总是很好奇。
And how did you manage playing cards for life asks?
你是如何应对生活的扑克牌的？
How did you guys track all the little details and stories happening over all the years and always impress me, especially those long term payoffs?
你们是如何追踪这些年来发生的所有小细节和故事并总是给我留下深刻的印象，尤其是那些长期回报？
If you could say a little about that and about, I would say like, what's the on balance?
如果你能谈谈这一点，我会说，总的来说是什么？
How many things were long term payoffs that you really planted or that you years later were like, Hey, here's an idea of how to bring something back.
有多少东西是你真正种植的长期回报，或者几年后你会想，嘿，这是一个如何带回一些东西的想法。
We never plan not bringing back.
我们从来没有计划不带回来。
Right.
正确的。
A lot of the long-term payoffs were planned.
许多长期回报都是计划好的。
We love that kind of long-term thinking, but then we would like fuck up the sofa, right?
我们喜欢这种长期思考，但随后我们会想把沙发搞砸，对吧？
From the end of season one of beginning of season two, the sofa changes in the span of 30 seconds, and you'd be like, oh yeah, we forgot about that.
从第一季结束到第二季开始，沙发在 30 秒内发生变化，你会说，哦，是的，我们忘了这一点。
We're planning something that's going to pay off in season four, so that'll be cool.
我们正在计划一些将在第四季中获得回报的事情，所以这会很酷。
And I think we were maybe better at some of the long-term stuff than occasionally screwing up something like fumbling a really easy pass.
我认为我们可能在一些长期的事情上做得更好，而不是偶尔搞砸一些事情，比如笨手笨脚地传球。
We would go for like the Hail Mary, but like, you know, ADR touchdown pass and fumble like the little handoff.
我们会像万福玛丽那样努力，但就像，你知道的，ADR 达阵传球和像小交接一样的掉球。
And like we had a funny record of sometimes screwing up very easy things.
就像我们有一个有趣的记录，有时会把很简单的事情搞砸。
But yeah, a lot of those long-term things were planned.
但是，是的，很多长期的事情都是计划好的。
We kept our writers assistants kept a running list of like things that we planted that we have to pay off later.
我们让我们的编剧助理保留了一份连续的清单，上面列出了我们种植的、稍后必须偿还的东西。
And that was like a running file in the writers room.
这就像编剧室里的一个正在运行的文件。
And sometimes we'd write something up on a board to remember it, you know, future selves.
有时我们会在黑板上写下一些东西来记住它，你知道，未来的自己。
We have to pay this off at the end of the season.
我们必须在赛季结束时还清这笔钱。
Sometimes we'd not think of it at all ahead of time and we'd just realize, wait, we can kind of retroactively create a set up payoff situation if we do X, Y, and Z.
有时我们根本不会提前想到这一点，我们只是意识到，等等，如果我们执行 X、Y 和 Z，我们可以追溯性地创建一个已设定的回报情况。
And we always loved when things echoed and resonated and came back around, even in this conversation and this IG Live of this today's episode is like, every, there's so many things in life that have set ups and payoffs, even if they only make sense later.
我们总是喜欢事物产生共鸣、产生共鸣并卷土重来，即使在这次对话和今天这一集的 IG Live 中，生活中也有很多事情都是有安排和回报的，即使它们只是在以后才有意义。
And one thing, the dominoes kind of fall in a certain way and you look back and you go, how did they fall exactly that way and it changed my life?
有一件事，多米诺骨牌以某种方式倒下，你回头看，你会发现它们是如何以某种方式倒下的，这改变了我的生活？
And so, yes, you have to, sometimes you plan those things, but sometimes you just, you go with them, you stumble upon it and you go, great, that's gonna make us look smart if we own that and retroactively create a payoff to something.
所以，是的，你必须这样做，有时你计划这些事情，但有时你只是，你跟着他们走，你偶然发现它，然后你就走了，太棒了，如果我们拥有它并追溯地为某事创造回报，这会让我们看起来很聪明。
We didn't even mean as a setup.
我们甚至不是故意设置的。
Josh, we've got a message to you, by the way, just say hello to Delson.
乔希，我们有消息给你，顺便向德尔森打个招呼。
I hope he's not too jealous of the baby.
希望他不要太嫉妒孩子了。
Oh, good question.
哦，好问题。
He's adjusting.
他正在调整。
I mean, he's not like a, he's not a brat, you know, So he's not gonna, but he's got a little more of a hanggog lookin' inside.
我的意思是，他不像一个，他不是一个孩子，你知道，所以他不会，但他的内心有更多的忧虑。
We went out for a family walk this morning and took the ball and we're throwing it in the park and he was, you know, he was having a great time.
今天早上我们一家人出去散步，接了球，我们把它扔到公园里，他，你知道，他玩得很开心。
So I think we just need to, we always try to remind ourselves like, like Nelson needs.
所以我认为我们只需要，我们总是试着提醒自己，就像纳尔逊需要的那样。
He was our only child for a while, you know?
有一段时间他是我们唯一的孩子，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Dominic, and another ongoing theme of today, Dominic Borboa says, I'm skipping, I'm skipping my online karate class for this.
多米尼克，以及今天的另一个持续主题，多米尼克·博尔博亚说，我要逃课，我为此要逃课在线空手道课程。
Everything about that.
关于那件事的一切。
That raises more questions than it answers, but I like it.
这提出的问题多于答案，但我喜欢它。
But I like it.
但我喜欢它。
We can guide you through some karate to close.
我们可以指导您完成一些空手道以结束。
Why don't we just, let's just do some slow elegant movements.
我们为什么不做一些缓慢优雅的动作呢？
Everyone can probably use a little bit of a physical.
每个人都可以使用一点体力。
Between the two of us, we can come up with some karate on the fly, right?
我们两个人可以即时想出一些空手道，对吗？
Jonathan Zubia wants us to know that he found a baby bird in the alley.
乔纳森·祖比亚想让我们知道他在巷子里发现了一只小鸟。
There might be some slim pickings on this week's.
本周可能会有一些小的选择。
Is that, cause that, cause there's a photo that accompanies that statement, don't open an alley.
就是那个，因为那个，因为有一张照片，附有那句话，不要开小巷。
Cause that's definitely a dong.
因为那绝对是个东。
That is a hundred percent a dong reference.
这是百分百的洞参考。
That's a punchy dong reference, if I ever heard one.
如果我听过的话，这是一个有力的参考。
and well-played sir, but please don't send the photo.
先生打得很好，但请不要发送照片。
Oh, we've been asked about any progress on the people will dance merch.
哦，我们被问到《People will dance》商品有什么进展吗？
Oh.
哦。
We love this idea, don't we?
我们喜欢这个主意，不是吗？
We do.
我们做到了。
Let's work this out right here on the pod.
让我们在 Pod 上解决这个问题。
Craig, what do we think the legal ramifications are of us creating progress?
克雷格，我们认为我们创造进步的法律后果是什么？
Yes, it's always good to be recording your conversations about legal things.
是的，记录有关法律问题的谈话总是好的。
So this is on the record between the three of us.
所以这是我们三个人之间的记录。
And however many people are listening.
不管有多少人在听。
My lawyer is furiously texting me not to answer that question, Alex, so I'm gonna...
我的律师发短信让我不要回答这个问题，亚历克斯，所以我要……
It'd be hilarious if they shut us down for taking three common words from one episode of a show.
如果他们因为我们从一集节目中摘取三个常用词而将我们关闭，那就太搞笑了。
They're like, no, Disney owns that phrase.
他们说，不，迪士尼拥有这个短语。
Like, what a weird thing.
就像，多么奇怪的事情啊。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I mean, people will dance from the pilot of How I Met Your Mother, where Ted is being asked, you know, Marshall has just gotten engaged to Lilly, and he says, look, it's not like I, you know, think about my wedding all the time, and then he goes into this incredibly detailed list of what he needs from his wedding, which culminates in Band-No DJ.
是的，我的意思是，人们会在《老爸老妈的浪漫史》试播集里跳舞，泰德被问到，你知道，马歇尔刚刚和莉莉订婚，他说，看，这不像我，你知道，一直想着我的婚礼，然后他列出了他在婚礼中需要什么的极其详细的清单，最后在乐队 DJ 中达到了高潮。
People will dance.
人们会跳舞。
I'm not going to worry about it.
我不会为此担心。
And I shared that this had become a kind of mantra for me of like, faith that things will work out.
我分享说，这已经成为我的一种口头禅，相信事情会成功。
Like, people will dance.
就像，人们会跳舞。
I don't have to stress a bit, I don't have to sweat over it, I don't have to worry about it.
我不必有一点压力，我不必为此流汗，我不必担心。
And I've had a number of people say they either got a tattooed or they'll come up to me at a show and say, well, you write people will dance so I can get a tattoo.
有很多人说他们要么纹身了，要么在演出中走到我面前说，好吧，你写的是人们会跳舞，这样我就可以纹身了。
And then we came up with this idea that we wanted to do some merch that just said people will dance.
然后我们想到了这个想法，我们想做一些只是说人们会跳舞的商品。
And it's very, if you know, you know.
如果你知道的话，你就知道了。
But also there's something about the phrase itself, people will dance that is like inherently makes you feel good and optimistic, right?
但这句话本身也有一些东西，人们会跳舞，这本身就让你感觉良好和乐观，对吧？
Like, people will dance.
就像，人们会跳舞。
Like dancing is a sign of exuberance and joy and it's gonna happen.
就像跳舞是活力和欢乐的标志一样，它将会发生。
So.
所以。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, let's talk.
好吧，我们来谈谈吧。
I'll get it.
我会得到它。
We'll talk to John Morrow about the font.
我们将与约翰·莫罗讨论该字体。
Let's hope it's not people will sue if we make you sure it's.
希望如果我们确定是的话，人们不会起诉。
I think also, and Josh, you've mentioned this on the podcast that you created at one of your company, you named it your neighbor company, People Dance.
我想，乔什，你在你的一家公司创建的播客中提到了这一点，你将其命名为你的邻居公司 People Dance。
I feel like that gives us legal, legal footing.
我觉得这给了我们合法的、合法的立足点。
Yeah, it's if you're a fan of my corporation You want to wear a shirt that shouts it out, yeah Alec you're not a lawyer correct.
是的，如果你是我公司的粉丝，你想穿一件能大声喊出来的衬衫，是的，亚历克，你不是律师，对吧。
You're not in fact a lawyer.
你实际上不是律师。
So we're not I just want not a good lawyer.
所以我们不是我只是想要一个好的律师。
Let me tell you that By the way mark rampage shut out to to mark who says I'm in my film class watching this Well, we can't film that can we we can't encourage that kind of rap scallion re Yeah.
让我告诉你，顺便说一下，马克·拉普奇（Mark Ramage）被拒之门外，以标记谁说我在电影课上看这个好吧，我们不能拍摄那个，我们可以吗？我们不能鼓励那种说唱葱是的。
We're honored.
我们很荣幸。
And as we close this out, I always like to find two sort of bigger questions here.
当我们结束这个问题时，我总是喜欢在这里找到两个更大的问题。
So let's go with this one, which is Elizabeth G.
让我们来看看这位，她就是伊丽莎白·G (Elizabeth G)。
Wareham asks, what is surprised you all the most about re-watching the show so far?
韦勒姆问，到目前为止，重看这部剧最令你惊讶的是什么？
I would say just how good it is.
我会说它有多好。
Like I had a you know if you if you've listened to me on other podcasts or even listen to this podcast you'll know that I had and continue to have although it's really dimming considerably a somewhat conflicted relationship with um being conflated with a character or being called a character's name that's not my real name like me being very clear that I'm an actor playing a role but other people saying like you are this person and you have to be this person and I refuse to accept you as anyone but this person and it was all very uh in terms of identity it was very destabilizing.
就像我有一个你知道的，如果你在其他播客上听过我的节目，甚至听过这个播客，你就会知道我曾经并且继续拥有过，尽管它确实相当暗淡，但与嗯与一个角色混为一谈或被称为一个角色的名字这有点冲突的关系，这不是我的真名，就像我很清楚我是一个扮演角色的演员，但其他人说你就是这个人，你必须是这个人，我拒绝接受你作为任何人，但这个人，就身份而言，这一切都非常呃，非常不稳定。
And so I think psychologically I had to create some, I was trying to create some distance between myself and the show and I forgot that it was a really good show.
所以我认为从心理上我必须创造一些，我试图在自己和节目之间创造一些距离，但我忘记了这是一个非常好的节目。
And I forgot that people love it for a reason.
我忘记了人们喜欢它是有原因的。
And you know, I didn't even watch all the episodes when they were on the air.
你知道，当它们播出时我什至没有看完所有剧集。
I probably saw like 40, 45 percent of the episodes like throughout the run.
我可能在整个运行过程中看了大约 40%、45% 的剧集。
So I'm seeing some of these episodes for the first time and I'm able to all these years later You're somewhat dispassionately watch it and objectively see that this was a great show that I was a part of.
所以我第一次看到其中一些剧集，这么多年后我能够冷静地观看它并客观地看到这是一部我参与的精彩节目。
I'm really proud to be a part of the show.
我真的很自豪能成为这个节目的一部分。
My wife even said that when, how I met your mother fans, come up to me and want to talk about the show, she said, since you've been doing the podcast, you're a lot warmer.
我老婆还说，什么时候，我怎么认识你妈妈的粉丝，来找我，想聊聊节目，她说，自从你做了播客，就温暖多了。
And I think it's also because I understand what they're enthusiastic about.
我想这也是因为我了解他们热衷的是什么。
And I'm not thinking that they're assaulting me or being, you know, making me, putting me in some strange box.
我并不认为他们在攻击我，或者，你知道，他们在制造我，把我放在一个奇怪的盒子里。
They just want to talk about this thing that I was a part of that they really love.
他们只是想谈论我是他们真正喜欢的事情的一部分。
So I've been able to become a fan of the show, which is a very cool thing, and it's really helped contextualize the show in my life as this really special thing that I was a part of and not something I need to run away from, but something I can fully embrace.
所以我已经能够成为这个节目的粉丝，这是一件非常酷的事情，它确实帮助我将这个节目融入到我的生活中，因为我是这个非常特别的事情的一部分，而不是我需要逃避的东西，而是我可以完全拥抱的东西。
Yeah, I'm so happy for you that you are getting that.
是的，我为你感到高兴，因为你明白了。
I'm so happy for you.
我真为你高兴。
I really am.
我确实是。
You deserve to feel that.
你值得感受到这一点。
You were really good on that really good show, and my answer is the same answer.
你在那个非常精彩的节目中表现得非常好，我的答案也是同样的答案。
sweating over every detail in the moment 20 years ago, 15 years ago, you know, all through that whole the whole show.
20 年前、15 年前，你知道，贯穿整场演出，我们都在为每一个细节而流汗。
And then looking back at these episodes, and I'm not worried about the sound mix, I'm not worried about whether scene six had a good enough blow at the end of the scene.
然后回顾这些剧集，我并不担心混音，我也不担心第六场在场景结束时是否有足够好的打击。
I'm not worried about, wait, oh, I did is the C story.
我不担心，等等，哦，我做的是C故事。
I'll blow as a joke at the end of the scene.
场景结束时我会开个玩笑。
It's coming to me, please don't sue me.
它来找我了，请不要起诉我。
I'm not creating an answer and say work environment here.
我不会在这里创建答案并说工作环境。
And, you know, I'm not obsessed with I just think that C-story in that one episode wasn't as good as it could have been.
而且，你知道，我并不痴迷于我只是认为那一集中的 C 故事没有达到应有的效果。
No, it just, all of that's gone.
不，只是，一切都过去了。
And even if I see something, I could, that could have been better.
即使我看到了什么，我也可以，那本来可以更好。
It's like, it's so, it's not even a blip on the radar for me now, the spirit of the show.
就好像，就是这样，这对我来说甚至不是雷达上的一个亮点，这部剧的精神。
I watch the show and I feel it's spirit and it's energy and it's heart.
我看这个节目，我感受到它的精神、它的能量、它的心灵。
It feels like something that is its own thing.
感觉就像是它自己的东西。
It's not my identity is not writing on it.
这不是我的身份，上面没有写。
Your identity is not writing on it.
上面没有写你的身份。
It just is this thing in the world that really belongs to the fans now.
现在这个世界上的东西才是真正属于粉丝的。
And we get to watch it kind of as fans now too.
我们现在也可以像粉丝一样观看它。
And that's wonderful.
这太棒了。
And also not breaking it apart into small pieces with which we obsessively examine each piece, even though we're kind of doing that on the show, but really, we made a nine-year movie.
而且我们也没有把它分成小块，我们着迷地检查每一个部分，尽管我们在节目中这样做，但实际上，我们制作了一部历时九年的电影。
Like we made this big, huge, sprawling story that people just love and watch over and over and over again and give them so much comfort and joy.
就像我们制作了这个宏大、宏大、庞大的故事一样，人们会一遍又一遍地喜欢和观看，并给他们带来如此多的安慰和快乐。
And I just feel like there's something about looking at it as a big, almost like a triptych or something like a story that winds around all the walls and you just move from panel to panel.
我只是觉得把它看成一个大的、几乎像三联画或类似故事的东西，缠绕在所有的墙上，你只需从一个面板移动到另一个面板。
There's, yeah.
有，是的。
Yeah, and it doesn't live or die on one of those panels.
是的，它不会在其中一个面板上生或死。
It is the whole thing.
这就是整个事情。
And I see it as the whole thing now.
我现在将其视为整个事情。
And that is a great feeling and it's not one that I fully had at the time.
这是一种很棒的感觉，但我当时并没有完全体会到这种感觉。
Well, for final word here, just for you Josh, Barry Likumahua says, by the way, Josh, we missed Jordan's questions and observations, We should good health for Jordana and the baby.
好吧，最后一句话，只对你说，乔什，巴里·利库马华说，顺便说一句，乔什，我们错过了乔丹的问题和观察，我们应该祝乔丹娜和宝宝健康。
Jordana is the most popular part of this podcast.
乔丹娜是这个播客中最受欢迎的部分。
That's what we've learned.
这就是我们所学到的。
She's killing her her IG live right now.
她现在正在搞死她的 IG 直播。
Like she always, that's such a power move.
就像她一贯的那样，这是一个充满力量的举动。
She always launches a cock eating at you.
她总是发射一只鸡巴来吃你。
It's obnoxious that she schedules them at the exact same time as ours.
令人讨厌的是她把它们安排在与我们完全相同的时间。
And that it's double the number of viewers, listeners.
而且观众、听众的数量是原来的两倍。
That's heartbreaking to us.
这让我们心碎。
Now, Jordana is great.
现在，乔丹娜很棒。
She has been busy with this little human.
她一直在忙着照顾这个小人类。
Yeah.
是的。
So there is that.
所以就是这样。
We're trying to pull her out of retirement.
我们正在努力让她摆脱退休生活。
Yeah.
是的。
But I'm so glad people loved her questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met a mother who also happens to be married to Josh.
但我很高兴人们喜欢她的问题和来自一位临床心理学家的观察，这位临床心理学家从未见过我是如何遇到一位恰好与乔什结婚的母亲的。
With a catchy name like that, how can we not bring that segment back?
这么朗朗上口的名字，怎能不把那一段带回来呢？
I know.
我知道。
But we've heard so consistently from people who miss it.
但我们不断听到怀念它的人们的声音。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Every time.
每次。
Every week.
每个星期。
Yeah.
是的。
So I'll pass on the garage.
所以我会放弃车库。
She'll be, she's very touched by it.
她会的，她对此非常感动。
And that message from Barry says, wishing good health for Jordana and the baby from Indonesia.
巴里发来的信息说，祝愿乔丹娜和来自印度尼西亚的婴儿身体健康。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Beautiful.
美丽的。
It's nice.
很好。
Alec, I couldn't help notice we didn't hear from Eliza, who claims she was named after my grandmother Rose.
亚历克，我不禁注意到我们没有收到伊丽莎的消息，她声称她是以我祖母罗斯的名字命名的。
It's not an entry line if we don't get one of those comments.
如果我们没有收到这些评论之一，那么它就不是一个入门行。
Where is Eliza Rose?
伊丽莎·罗斯在哪里？
But never the answer.
但始终没有答案。
Never the answer to what it means.
从来没有答案是什么意思。
All right, it's going to keep going.
好吧，一切都会继续下去。
It's a serious long mystery, maybe at the end of the podcast.
这是一个严肃而漫长的谜团，也许在播客的结尾。
And an answer to several people's questions.
并回答了几个人的问题。
Yes, the audio from what you've just experienced will be available as a podcast episode.
是的，您刚刚体验过的音频将作为播客剧集提供。
Several, I want to say months from now, weeks, months from now.
有几个，我想说几个月后、几周后、几个月后。
So this will be here.
所以这会在这里。
So if your question was asked and you want to prove that to other folks, it will be recorded, and you will have access to that in hell of a month.
因此，如果你的问题被问到，并且你想向其他人证明这一点，它就会被记录下来，你将在一个月内访问到它。
So that's our Instagram live for today.
这就是我们今天的 Instagram 直播。
Thanks everybody.
谢谢大家。
Have a great time.
玩得很开心。
Thank you so much for tuning in.
非常感谢您的收听。
and if you're loving the podcast, please spread the word.
如果您喜欢这个播客，请传播出去。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please acquit me.
请释放我无罪。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪孽都被宽恕。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 主持并监制，并由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matata。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, AKA Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作《事情不是这样发生的》，无论书在哪里出售，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own dead father's society, also on Substack.
你也可以订阅我已故父亲的社团，也在 Substack 上。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Real question, it just hit me, or just New York City.
真正的问题，它刚刚击中了我，或者只是纽约市。